PRADEEPTA DASH: LinkedIn is
the premier social network
for professionals.
We are consistently one of
the top apps on Google Play.
My name is Pradeepta Dash.
I am the engineering manager
for LinkedIn and for such a team
for the flagship apps.
We have a million-plus reviews.
We are consistently 4+ stars.
Our users are really
appreciative of how
stable the app is,
how it really helps
them bring their
professional profile power.
DREW HANNAY: My
name is Drew Hannay.
I'm on the Android
Infrastructure
team at LinkedIn.
My team is responsible for the
overall health of our Android
application.
We take care of releases
to Google Play, our testing
pipeline for the app,
or build pipeline.
One of the tools that my
team has been excited about
is the APK analyzer tool
because we spend a lot of time
paying attention to
the size of our app,
and it required some
expertise to figure out
what is causing your app
to be a certain size.
But now that we have
the APK analyzer tool,
we've been able to
expand that knowledge
throughout the entire team.
LinkedIn was an early
adopter of Gradle.
So adopting Gradle for Android
was a pretty natural fit for us
because we share a lot of
our custom plug-in logic
that we've built,
and we can also
get consistent builds
across developer machines
and our build service.
One thing that's
really benefited
us is the Lint system, which
has a lot of built-in checks
for common problems.
And we've really
appreciated being
able to write our
own custom Lint
checks for LinkedIn-specific
internal libraries.
With so many developers
checking into the code base,
one thing that helps
onboarding someone new
is having a consistent code
style throughout the code base.
Android Studio lets us
define a custom code style
that each developer can
add and automatically
have their code formatted
in the LinkedIn style.
PRADEEPTA DASH:
One of the things
that we really appreciate
is the open nature
of the platform, where not only
has the feedback that been have
given back to the developer
community been accepted,
but also being worked upon.
In the last couple
of years, my team
has become very faster,
much more agile,
and being able to code easier
and faster on the Android
Studio.